jetzt kommen wir zu einem thema über das
plötzlich alle reden und das bis neulich
scheinbar kein schwein interessiert hat
die pflege ja deutschlands politiker
entdecken den pflegenotstand höchste
zeit wird
und alles nur wenn wir darüber nachdenkt
alles nur weil ein junger pfleger der
kanzlerin neulich die meinung gegeigt
hat es gibt menschen die ligen stunden
lang in ihren ausscheidungen das sind
menschen die haben dieses land aufgebaut
die pflege ist so überlastet und sie
sind seit zwölf jahren an der regierung
und haben in meinen augen nicht viel für
die pflege getan so was denkt merkel in
der sekunde wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich wenn politik auf
wirklichkeit trifft unsere kliniken und
altenheime suchen händeringend personal
in vielen häusern ist ein einzelner
pfleger nachts ganz allein für über 50
patienten zuständig es ist fakt dass
sind da zu sein und wenn die wenn die
pflegekräfte streiken wie in den letzten
wochen dann nicht mal für mehr geld den
traum haben die längst aufgegeben
sondern für mehr personal
die zeit dass man sich mal zu einem
sterbenden patienten hinsetzen kann
die gibt es einfach nicht es wird
geguckt dass auf dem monitor schnell die
betten frei werden damit man gleich
wieder neu belegen kann ja seine totale
schande
wir sind eines der reichsten länder des
planeten und trotzdem muss eine deutsche
pflegekraft viel mehr menschen versorgen
als in den meisten anderen zivilisierten
ländern
da liegen wir bei krankenhäuser zum
beispiel weit unter oecd schnitt
man bräuchte sage ich und das sage ich
man bräuchte endlich einen gesetzlichen
bundesweiten personalschlüssel der dann
auch mal überprüft wird ist doch ein
wunder das überhaupt noch irgendwer in
deutschland freiwillig in der pflege
arbeitet die ist personal muss mehr geld
haben damit überhaupt jemanden haftenden
beruf überhaupt greift umso toller dass
die beiden es trotzdem machen oder
ich mache einen kleinen bogen genug
sehen
ein bisschen um den titel
da muss dann muss sie beim nächsten
klingeln wahrscheinlich etwas länger
warten würde ich sagen naja immerhin
dass es ja eine reform aus dem letzten
jahr immerhin müssen altenpfleger in
deutschland ihre ausbildung neuerdings
nicht mehr selber bezahlt ganz toll und
alles weitere
liebe freunde sagt dieses kinderlied
[Musik]
zehn kleine flieger weinheims ruin
der eine kriegt ein herzinfarkt am
bahnhof neu-ulm kleine flieger haben in
den weg gemacht
der eine ist kauf ausgerutscht dann
kannst du noch 88 kleine flieger war
mundstuhl schäden wie eine oma war zu
spät
ganze 72 kleine tiger leib tragen oper 1
der einer und der eingespart da fast nur
noch ein kleines lied allein bleibt
nicht nur im heim ist kann ich diesen
schweine job dann sieht man doch allein
ja das ist die realität
personal
jetzt jetzt ist ja schon so bei den
ihrer not legen viele menschen ihre
angehörigen schon zu hause weiß nich
anders geht schlimm traurig und alle
deutschen parteien 18 uhr darauf
wirklich alle deutschen parteien finden
jetzt plötzlich man müsste erst mal mehr
für die pflege tun so allgemein
dabei wird das eigentliche problem
komplett ignoriert 2013 hat die damalige
überraschung schwarz gelbe
bundesregierung die pflege gesetze
zugunsten von privatanbietern reformiert
seitdem geht es auch in der pflege immer
mehr um effizienz und kosten sparen
danke fdp und wie viel an gewinnen
letztendlich dann auch an die
aktienhalter ausgeschüttet wird dann
geht 50 dem system viel geld verloren ja
aber vielleicht ohne frage vielleicht
wissen aber die privaten besser und
effizienter mit dem geld umzugehen
vielleicht aber nur vielleicht sollte
christian lindner eine woche als
altenpfleger arbeiten oder ein jahr
vielleicht
nochmal zehn jahre vielleicht
viel auftrieb arten können besser mit
geld umgehen ja klar die sparen beim
personal zu gunsten der aktionäre in
vielen privaten altenheim gelten nicht
mal tarifverträge